there's not a lot of room here in the
cold storage today the company every
fois imports as much fish in one day as
they did in a whole month five years ago
manager Jeremy tapi be inspects the fish
that were caught in Senegal there's been
a jump in consumer demand off the back
of ivory coast's economic boom Elizabeth
Moore there was a massive slump during
the crisis after the last election and
we sold almost nothing but things have
really been on the up here for quite
some time now the supporters of
president Alassane Ouattara praise him
for bringing stability to ivory coast
after years of Civil War and political
crisis our dough as he's known here is
heavily favored to win a second term in
Sunday's presidential elections since
the political crisis after the last
elections the economy in Ivory Coast has
been growing between seven and ten
percent every year but critics say that
only few Ivorians benefit from the
economic boom in the country and
sometimes occur for me for those of us
in the informal economy things haven't
changed much but it's okay so like when
you would do the impossible sure they've
been improvements in the infrastructure
new bridges and streets are being built
but I haven't really noticed any
improvements in my day-to-day life song
called AMA via a VW more to us almost
everything has changed for the better I
can't complain and Jeremy tar PV
continues to expect solid gains for the
fish import business he manages he
firmly believes that the presidential
elections won't change that